Let's get some experience in comparing
and the calculation of ratios.
It is said that in one pet shop there are three aquariums,
each containing a different volume of water
and a different number of fish.
So, Aquarium A has 5 fish and contains 40 liters of water,
aquarium B - 12 fish and 100 liters of water,
and an aquarium C - 23 fish and contains 180 liters of water.
Sort the aquariums according to the volume of water per 1 number of fish
from the smallest to the largest.
Let us think of what a volume of fish means,
as we can see it as the volume divided into fish.
Volume of one fish count.
Okay, here for Aquarium A
we will have 40 liters
for all 5 fish.
40 for all 5 fish and see,
40 on 5 is 8,
so you got 8 liters of water for each fish.
This is the rate at which water should be added to each fish
for aquarium A.
In aquarium B you have 100 liters
for 12 fish,
so how much will it be?
This will be, 12 is contained in 100 eight times,
8 at 12 is 96 and then you stay 4.
We will have 8 and 4/12
or 8 and 1/3 liters of fish.
I just turned this irregular liver,
100 on 12, in mixed number and simplified it.
12 is contained in 100 eight times with residue 4,
so we have 8 and 4/12,
which is the same as 8 and 1/3.
And finally in the C aquarium
I have 180 liters
for 23 fish.
How much will it be?
23 is contained in 180 - let me try to calculate it.
23 is contained in 180 - it seems it will
be less than 9 times.
Eight times?
8, no, it's not eight times.
Let's see, 7 times.
7 in 3 is 21, 7 in 2 is 14,
plus 2 is 16.
When you pull out, you get a 19.
So this will be 7 with a remainder of 19
or you can say it is 7
and 19/23 liters
of a fish.
So which one of them ...
We will arrange the aquariums by volume of a number of fish,
from the smallest to the largest.
Aquarium B has the largest volume of water for fish,
there are 8 and 1/3 liters of a fish,
so he's first.
Then Aquarium A is second.
Aquarium A is second.
And then Aquarium C is in third place.
Oh, we really want to sort them from the smallest to the biggest,
so it will be - let me write it this way.
Aquarium C is the smallest,
but tank A has the largest volume.
In fact, we need to reverse this order.
I just copied this
from an exercise by the Cannes Academy.
Let's open up the actual exercise
and we can arrange them.
C was the smallest,
and B was the largest,
we check our answer and we get it right.